the girag an experience of course the
other thing that we always are up
against is the mindset that people have
got into about aging that they've needed
to get into for all these millennia that
we have been unable to do anything about
it or have any prospect of doing
anything about it at any time so you
know what are you going to do you've got
this terrible ghastly thing that's going
to happen to you in the distant future
and um you can't do anything about it
so you've got to put it out of your mind
so you're not going to spend you don't
want to spend your life being
preoccupied by it so you've got to find
some way to like not think about it and
get on with your miserably short life
and make the best of it right um and of
course the work the only way one can do
that is by somehow denying somehow
tricking oneself into denying that this
is such a big deal you know and thereby
pretending for example that it's not
really like a medical problem at all you
know it's like inevitable and Universal
and natural or alternatively saying well
okay maybe we could fix it if we want to
but it would be a bad thing that aging
is some kind of blessing in disguise and
that's where all the hates answer yeah
and that's where all this stuff comes
from about oh dear well we put all the
people or how we pay the pensions or
what dictators live forever or will it
be boring you know which I have to spend
my whole life contending with how do you
say well you get over the dictators
living for everyone well you know last
time I looked
dictator was fairly high on the league
table of risky jobs you know dictators
die of Aging in the furthermore the ones
that do die of Aging they tend to a
Vogon life a succession in advance
anyway so it's as if they were already
immortal so I mean come on
not only the percentage of dictators
versus the percentage of regular people
it's so incredibly small to not cure
aging because of dictators seems like
the dumbest idea ever well there you go
I mean but people are really you know
yes this is what people do right they
will come up with some reason why aiding
and abetting in disguise and then they
will instantly switch off their brains
for fear of actually coming up with a
refutation of that reason or even yeah
you know because romantic aspects of
Aging and the weird ones right yeah you
know the inevitable like it though it's
fine it's wonderful I'm looking forward
to it it's it's essentially a disease
that we all get yeah I mean to
I have to be very careful with the word
disease some people aren't so you've had
David Sinclair oh yes he's been a great
friend of mine for a lot of years and
we've yeah we have a very similar
attitude to you know Authority we don't
think much of it and so we tend to push
the boundaries a bit both of us you know
in somewhat different ways so he
actually hear that his view of calling
aging a disease is a bit different from
mine he's more comfortable with it I
tend to feel that the problem is a
problem with corrugating a disease which
is that it makes it sound like it's
something that could be cured with a
one-off therapy like like you know an
infection which is which it isn't it's a
side effect of being alive and as such
it's something that you know you can
repair you can stave off but you have to
do it periodically because the damage is
going to continue to be created and you
know the reason why that's important is
that it determines what kind of what
kind of medicine we look for a lot of
Alzheimer's research for example in fact
I would say most of Alzheimer's research
has been predicated on this kind of
mistake on the idea that if we can just
cure Outsiders they know so I would say
that actually it's not that the word
disease is used to narrowly and should
be broadened to include aging rather
it's the other way around that the word
disease is used too broadly and should
be narrowed so it's not to include
things like Alzheimer's that are
actually parts of Aging because really
the difference between the progressive
chronic conditions like Alzheimer's that
we call diseases and the ones that we
don't like you know loss of muscle or
declining the immune system or whatever
you know the only difference is
semantics some of them you know there
are both parts of ating just some of
them are ones that we've chosen to give
to these like names - what would you
call aging if you don't call it disease
well I call it a medical problem right
that's all I call it okay that's pretty
pure yeah yeah
in terms of
potential future treatments stem cells
seem to be very promising there are
there other competing treatments that
you think are equally promising yes sure
but they're not competing so um so as I
said because this is a divide and
conquer problem with a bunch of
different types of damage all of which
we need to fix then we need to look at
the well fixes are available for each
individual type so what stem cells are
there to fix is so loss where cells are
dying and they're not being
automatically replaced in the body by
cell division have you personally
experienced a stem cell therapy no I
haven't done any therapy for any of any
kind yet but of course you know I'm
paying attention yeah I'll see you know
of course the way the nature of Aging is
that because it's progressive and
because it's only it only causes
functional decline after a certain point
there's a trade-off that one always has
to keep in mind in terms of timing of a
therapy between how badly one needs it
and how rapidly the quality of the
therapy is improving so you know if I
take a stem-cell therapy now then
there's a chance that'll be bad for me
for whatever reason okay whereas ten
years down the road I will still yeah I
would have needed it for those ten years
today's other other may start to need it
bit more but it will have benefitted
from ten years more of research and
refinement so you're a cautious paycheck
oh sure I mean I don't think anybody
wants to be the first patient I'm in I
don't see I'll be the first guy I'm
already doing a bunch of stem cell
therapies will do intravenous stem cell
therapies - well sure but I mean the
point is you you weren't the first to do
any of these all for sure right yeah so
yes in terms of other things so
synthetics do not compete with stem
cells because the oolitic for that to do
a different thing to reflects a
different type of damage namely the
accumulation of these bad cells right
and then you've got to have you know
cancer therapies you've got to have
therapies that remove molecular waste
products through inside self a couple of
our startup companies have have doing
that you've got a remove waste products
from outside the cells for example so
people Livius the immune system to do
that you've got a repair DNA in
in the mitochondria these special parts
of the cell that do the chemistry of
breathing you know there's a bunch of
different things we have to do and
another piece of good news I told you
earlier on that there's been no real
change over the past 20 years and our
understanding of what the problem is
better than that
they'll also been no real need to change
our preferred approaches to each of to
each of the damage repair technologies
we haven't had we haven't you know found
bad news that said oh dear this
potential approach to fixing this
particular type of damage isn't going to
work for this new reason that we didn't
know before therefore we have to start
again and think of a new one that hasn't
happened to either
that's excellent so it's just
essentially refining the procedures or
grinding away and actually implementing
them
[Applause]